l'armée israélienne est à l'offensive
elle projette sans doute de pénétrer
dans la bande de gaza en tout cas d'y
mener des opérations et c'est certain
que d'avoir des médias confirmé que la
société de passe ou al jezira peuvent
poser problème dans la couverture de ces
opérations où justement dans la volonté
de les couvrir
le journalisme est devenu une cible un
peu partout pas seulement dans le cadre
du conflit israélo palestinien
les journalistes en particulier de notre
confrère olivier dubois qui a été enlevé
au mali le 8 avril dernier
c'est le dernier exemple en date d'un
journaliste il cible est utilisé pour
extorquer des rançons parfois le
journaliste est tout simplement tuer et
puis parfois c'est son équipement qui
est confisqué il ya une grave crise
aujourd'hui dans le monde et dans la
couverture des conflits tue de plus en
plus les journalistes sont devenus des
cibles la liberté de la presse est la
condition essentielle de l'existence
d'une démocratie la liberté de la presse
induit le droit à l'information
le public a le droit d'être informés
quand il ne peut pas être informé parce
que les journalistes ne peuvent faire
leur métier
mais ce soir côté hamas où que ce soit
côté israélien là cela pose un grave
problème cela pose évidemment le
problème du sens de la quête de vérité
et de savoir tout simplement ce qui se
passe dans cet endroit
même les etats-unis ont émis d'ailleurs
des doutes par la voix d'antony blinken
porte parole de la diplomatie américaine
il y a il ya une inquiétude émises par
les états unis ce qui est assez rare dû
au fait que les états unis son soutien
inconditionnel d'israël et dans ce cas
précis et dans le cas précis de cette la
destruction de cette tour qui on le
rappelle abritait les locaux depuis 15
ans la société de presse tap une vieille
agence de presse américaine et également
ceux d'al jazeera la première chaîne
qatarie est bien dans ce cas là les
américains ont émis quand même des
doutes ce qui nous laisse penser que les
choses ne sont pas si clair que ça